hey what is up guys i'm kphd here and
these are my quick first impressions of
the new big smartphones that samsung
announced today the main one you need to
know about is the galaxy note 5. it is
big it's bright crispy it's really dense
and slippery as hell so here's the
breakdown just like every year you know
the galaxy note gets improvements on the
inside and out and right off the bat on
the inside on paper the galaxy note 5
has a pretty dope looking spec sheet so
it's the octa-core exynos 7420 chip from
the galaxy s6 it's a bump up to 4
gigabytes of ram it's a 5.7 inch quad hd
super amoled display that looks pretty
outstanding it's a 16 megapixel camera
with optical image stabilization and the
f 1.9 aperture and it's a 3 000 milliamp
hour battery with fast charging and
wireless charging and nfc and lte
advanced and ac wi-fi etc it's even a
new color with this sweet looking
titanium gray
it's a very complete looking spec sheet
on paper but in practice it's not all
perfect so the main story with the note
5 is on the outside obviously the
biggest change here is in the hardware
design it's moved as we kind of expected
into this all metal and glass thin
railed look like the galaxy s6 and
samsung says you know premium materials
high-end precise build durable etc and
they've even curved the glass on the
back of the phone to fit better in one
hand so that actually works well and to
top it all off it fits inside the
footprint of the galaxy note 4 since the
bezels make it thinner and shorter and
narrower than its predecessor
i agree that the shape is better the
shape is actually great but the phone
itself is super slippery in the hand
it's just not really that comfortable to
hold it's like all the things that were
slippery about the galaxy s6 with that
glossy back uh magnified in an even
bigger body just the feel on the hand is
i guess definitely my least favorite
part of this phone that and the fact
that you now have all the internals
sealed meaning there's no removable
battery and there's also no expandable
storage those two things will be a
pretty big deal for some people i don't
mind them as much but i actually do care
a lot about the way it feels in the hand
there's also some pretty neat new
features though that really make it a
note first of all the s pen is improved
and you may be looking at it wondering
how do i get it out of the phone if it's
embedded like that well the stylus
actually has a clicking button on the
back and it just clicks and pops out of
the phone just like that and it is an
improved stylus made with more metal now
you know it has a little bit more weight
to it still has a button uh and that
multi-level sensitivity and as a bonus
you can keep clicking it even when it's
out of the phone no functionality there
but it is kind of addicting and the s
pen functionality itself is actually
improved too you can see the menu looks
a little bit different when you take it
out the phone and going into and
triggering the s pen actions works the
same with the improved pen uh it just
feels a little bit more natural to write
on the screen at the end of the day i
usually like see all these features and
i use them a little bit when i first get
the galaxy notes but then i use them
less and less as time goes on but today
they showed me one feature that i really
like and will definitely try to use more
you can bust out the stylus when the
display is off and then immediately
start writing on the screen so if you're
ever in a binding you heard something
that you just have to write down you
have to just break out your phone and
start to write it the s pen lets you
write it down real quick and when you
put the pen back it closes and saves
that note that is actually a really good
idea i like that there's also stuff
added to the galaxy note improved ways
to take like taller screenshots and ways
to annotate and share what you create
with this pen all of it makes sense and
all of that is what makes it a note
but all the rest is in your brand new
design also i mentioned the phone is
thinner with this new design which means
the battery as i mentioned is actually
smaller than the last galaxy note at 3
000 milliamp hours and non-removable now
they do try to make up for this and you
can decide if it's a good enough
replacement or not with wireless
charging and fast charging and get this
fast wireless charging so samsung's new
wireless charging technology lets them
get around 90 of normal fast charging
wired speeds without the wire i
personally would rather still have a
larger battery and a thicker phone
that's just me but you know we'll have
to see how good this battery lasts with
the quad hd display in the full review
and that's the real sentiment here i
didn't get to play with these phones for
too much time but i'm looking forward to
getting my hands on them like
permanently for a full review experience
preferably in this darker titanium color
to test things like the battery life to
test the performance to test things like
the built-in youtube live streaming
directly from the camera app at up to
1080p i mean this seems like it's
supposed to be a periscope killer but i
won't really know it until i try it uh
certainly seems really convenient for
people to live stream from their phones
especially since this is one of the best
cameras in any smartphone i'm not sure
if i'm looking forward to testing this
though
what year is it again but you know what
i'll give it that shot and actually try
to use it before i dismiss it entirely
overall the note 5 gets my hesitant but
optimistic wait and see also there was
another phone announced today the galaxy
s6 edge plus this one's easy it's the
galaxy s6 edge
but plus it's bigger
or you could also call it the galaxy
note 5 with curved edges both
descriptions would be correct it has the
updated specs and it's the bigger 5.7
inch display from the galaxy note
that is also curved on each side i've
used the galaxy s6 edge smaller version
as a daily driver for a while so i'll be
interested to see the new features one
of the new features of the s6 edge plus
is the ability to put not just your few
favorite contacts in the edge on your
home screen but to put any of your
favorite apps in there as well and also
to have this available on any screen so
it's sort of like a mini launcher of any
apps you want no restrictions this will
certainly be nice to have
so there you have it thanks for watching
and feel free to share this with others
curious about samsung's big new
flagships i'm definitely interested like
i said in using these full time and this
has just been my quick impressions and
hands-on again thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys the next one
peace
you